شكرا جزيلا من اوكرانيا الى المملكه
المتحده
تخيل دبابه تشالنجرانيه وجه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني الشكر الى المملكه المتحده التي
نفذت وعدها بتقديم المدرعات الثقيله الى
بلاده لمواجهه الهجوم الروسيه كما اشرف
شخصيا على الدبابات الالمانيه والامريكيه
التي وصلت لتوها الى اوكرانيا تشرفت اليوم
باختبار المركبات التي انضمت حديثا الى
وحداتنا المسلحه مع قائد قوات الهجوم
الجوي والمظاليين هي دبابات تشالنجر
البريطانيه
بالاضافه الى اربعين عربه مشاه قتاليه
المانيه من طراز موردر اكد المستشار
الالماني ارسال 18 دبابه ليوبارد نعم قمنا
بتسليم دبابات كما سبق ان اعلنا مع هولندا
والدنمارك سنرسل ايضا مركبات قتاليه مدرعه
وذخيره مشاه وليوبارت واحد لدعم اوكرانيا
مع وصول المركبات الثقيله تعتزم اوكرانيا
شان هجوم مضاد لاستعاده الاراضي التي
احتلتها روسيا وكذلك شبه جزيره القرم
لكن الروس لن يقفوا مكتوفي الايدي في ظل
دعم دول الغرب لاوكرانيا والسعي الى الحاق
الهزيمه بقواتها المسلحه لذا بدات تلويح
بالاسلحه النوويه وتعاهدت بيلاروسيا بنشر
اسلحه نوويه روسيه على اراضيها كرد على
الضغوط الغربيه واستعداد بريطانيا لتقديم
ذخائر اليورانيوم المستنفذ لاوكرانيا